(airplane soaring)
- [Narrator] Find your thing.
When you're trying to
with the career lottery,
sometimes the winning ticket is right
in front of you.
The answer to your most pressing questions
and the path to the
work you were born to do
may come from the people
you interact with everyday.
Everyone's an expert at something,
is a good principle to keep in mind.
And often the something
comes as a surprise.
But even if you know what your skills are,
a skill is only as valuable as the extent
to which people will pay you to use it.
How do you figure out
which our your skills
are most valuable and marketable?
Here's the core principle,
when you're not sure what your thing is,
when you don't know quite where to look
to find that job or career that brings you
joy, flow, and a good income
the people you talk to
everyday can help you find it.
The answer may come from your inbox,
whether that inbox consists of the actual
emails you receive with the
same questions over and over.
Your social media feeds
are just the conversations
you have with friends.
In other words, the people in your network
may actually have a
better sense of what your
most marketable skills are than you do.
The key, is looking to the
questions they ask you.
The favors they request of you.
And maybe even the books
or articles they send you,
simply because they think
you'd be interested.
When someone says hey can
I ask you for a favor?
And you already know what that
person is going to ask you,
you have your answer.
Think about it.
If you have trouble updating your phone,
whom do you ask for help?
If you've been going to the gym,
but not seeing results,
whom do you ask for workout advice?
When you're planning a trip abroad
and need to find a hotel,
whom do you ask recommendations?
Now think about it from
the other perspective.
Does everyone ask you for
help updating the phone,
or improving a workout,
or recommending a place
to stay while traveling.
If you look closely,
you'll probably find that
there are certain types
of advice that people
ask you for over and over.
Whether it's recommendations
for books and movies,
investing tips, or your thoughts on the
latest gadget that hit the market,
the advice people solicit from you is a
huge clue as to which of
your skills and expertise
is most in demand.
And therefore, probably
the most marketable.
Find your thing.
(airplane soaring)